- [Instructor] I suspect that
you might already be familiar
with the term mixture.
It really does mean
what you think it means.
If you take two or more substances
and you were to mix them together,
you are dealing with a mixture.
And it could be a solid,
a liquid or a gas.
Now there's fundamentally two
different types of mixtures.
There's heterogeneous mixtures.
And hetero, you're going
to see that prefix a lot,
means different.
So heterogeneous, this
is referring to mixtures
that if you look at it
from a macro point of view,
I'll do a heterogeneous liquid mixture.
And what I often think of
here at the extreme form
is where with my naked eye,
I could see that different
parts of the mixtures
have different concentrations
of the different things
that have been mixed up.
One example I often think
of is chocolate milk
that's not well mixed.
At the top you're going
to see these clumps
and depending where you are in the milk,
you can actually see it with your eye,
that you don't have
consistent concentrations
of the different substances.
The properties of the
mixtures are different,
depending on what part of
the mixture you look at.
Now, you can imagine if
there's heterogeneous mixtures,
the opposite would be
homogeneous mixtures.
Those would be mixtures
that when you look at it
from a macro point of
view, it looks consistent
any point of the mixture.
Homogeneous mixtures.
And homogeneous mixtures,
there's another term for it,
which you have probably heard.
They're also known as solutions.
And as I mentioned, when
we talk about mixtures,
we could be talking about
solid, liquid or gas.
Oftentimes in our head, we
think liquid immediately,
but it can be solid liquid or gas.
And so the same thing
is true for solutions.
You can have solid liquids or gases.
And an example of a
solid solution would be,
say a metal alloy.
Where at the macro level it's color,
how well does it conduct electricity?
How malleable is it?
How hard is it?
It looks like the properties are uniform
throughout the alloy.
If I have some type of metal alloy,
if I were to just look at it like this,
if I were to look at say bronze,
well, from my point of view,
it has the same properties
throughout the bronze.
And I should probably do
bronze in a more bronze color
right over here.
But if you were to look at it
with a very sensitive microscope
or based on the models
that we now know what is
going on in that metal,
in that alloy,
what's happening is you actually
have a mixture of metals.
But it is a homogeneous mixture of metals
because at a macro level,
you can't really see the differences.
Now at a micro level, you can,
because there are different
metals mixed in together
in this alloy.
Now, as can imagine you
also have liquid solutions
and in chemistry,
these are the ones that
we'll often deal most.
We will also deal with solid
and gas solutions as well.
And when I think of a
homogeneous liquid mixture
or a liquid solution, the one
that comes to mind for me,
but we'll see a lot of these
in our journey through
chemistry is salt water.
Salt water.
Salt water has sodium
chloride dissolved in water.
And if you were to go to the ocean,
and if you were to just
look at the salt water,
or if you were to measure its
properties, even in a lab,
you would see that the properties
throughout the salt water
seem to be uniform.
At a macro level, it
appears to be homogeneous.
It appears to be uniform.
But if you were to look
at what's happening
at an atomic level,
you would see that you
have your water molecules.
Let me draw the water like that.
That is the oxygen, each
of them has two hydrogens.
And this end is partially positive,
we've seen this multiple
times, the hydrogen end,
the oxygen end is partially negative.
And so when you dissolve
the sodium chloride,
the chloride anions
are attracted to the
positive ends of the water.
So maybe you have a chloride anion there.
And the sodium ions
would be attracted to the
negative end of the H2O.
So that's the sodium right over there.
So when you look at it
at a micro perspective,
you see that there are
different molecules,
but at a macro perspective,
the macro properties,
how it responds to different stimulus,
how well it conducts electricity,
what it even looks like,
it seems to be uniform.
Now to be clear, saltwater is
not the only liquid solution.
There's many types of liquid solutions.
In chemistry, we'll often see water
as our most common solvent.
That's the thing that
you have the most of,
the thing that other things
are getting dissolved in it.
The things that are getting dissolved
are called the solute,
in this case it would
be the sodium chloride
and the water is the solvent.
Let me write that down, solvent.
When you have a solution
where you have something
dissolved in water,
this is often called an
aqueous, aqueous solution.
And sometimes it's abbreviated aq.
Now, last but not least, we
haven't talked about gases yet.
And you can for sure
have a solution of gas.
And the one that's most common
is the one that you and I
are breathing right now.
The air around you is a gas solution.
It's macroscopic
properties seem consistent,
they seem uniform,
but we know that the gas around
us is a mixture of nitrogen,
of oxygen, of carbon dioxide,
as well as molecules of other things.
So a good example of a
gas solution would be air.
So I'll let you go there.
That's just a good primer
on what a mixture is,
the types of mixtures
and especially the subtype of a mixture,
which is a homogeneous mixture,
which we often call a solution.